one of the most visible things is this
war on the history of the West the war
on the history of a country like Britain
so that you know every single one of our
institutions from Kew Gardens to the
National Trust to the Tate to the
British library to the Globe Theater all
the things that are meant to be
effectively custodians of our history
have actually started to wage a war on
that history so that they present our
history as if there's just nothing good
about it and as I say one of the many
devastating things about this is that a
country and a culture and a society can
only be held together if first of all it
has some agreement on its past and
secondly it thinks that past is broadly
good because if you don't think you were
good in the past why would you do
anything in the present